il
[Musique]
nous
aujourd'hui c'est un grand jour la
famille zoua part en vacances ont beau
du caneton soir on a le temps est là
mais vous oubliez credo chiens n'ont pas
fait mal vite s'il vous plaît
le plat parade anti-opa fils ça crée ton
temps se voir
créé deux chiens profite pour se
dégourdir les pattes mais ma parole
quand on voit le fait exprès il est
encore reparti en oubliant credo chien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour toi allez viens avec moi
[Musique]
ou credo chien j'ai dit tantôt soit un
petit creux à on va pouvoir s'arrêter
pour pique [ __ ] 29 pas tonton soit il
l'a pas fait exprès pour ton doigt joue
maintenant avec le credo chiens non non
moi tout va tout et nous nous avons bien
compris ton soit essaie de faire perdre
le pauvre et de chiens
[Musique]
vous connaissez l'histoire du petit
poucet
[Musique]
il
trop pauvre credo chien voilà perdus
dans la forêt
[Musique]
et nous on pleure pas créé de chiens
c'est une idée de watou à tout pour te
ramener à la voiture
[Musique]
papa maintenant par mois mais oui plus
de créneaux chien leveaux narval a créé
deux chiens sont en colère tu as ton
soit au nom était bien puisque c'est
comme ça en employant les grands moyens
[Musique]
et voilà c'est gagné elisabeth pique une
colère mais nous colère à naples le fond
crado chien elle ne veut plus bouger il
n'y a rien à faire et tout en soi n'a
plus qu'à retourner à pied à l'endroit
où il a jeté créneau chien
[Musique]
à
pendant que tonton voies contournent la
colline nous nous allons prendre un
raccourci maintenant c'est au tour de
tout on doit d'être abandonnée c'est
bientôt
merci voit tout bateau
[Musique]
et